which I explained to everyone what the V  Friends game is or will they pick it up  as we're playing all these cards have  numbers on them and we're just gonna go  one two three flip and that is how it's  played pretty good yeah yeah let's go  one two three flip me you got that one  57 55 60 61. let's [ __ ] go all right  one two three flip guys I'm one of the  great players  one two three flip guys I'm on fire  oh my God  whoa I like this guy first parallel  burglar and so when you get a parallel  yeah the score bounces up I cannot  believe I ever lost nobody's ever won  the spinning around ever You Gotta Give  me one man  [ __ ] crazy if you're watching this  this is I need somebody to give me the  math around what's happening right now  in the comments please wine glass B to B  nope shoot